jamaica is not a part of canada seems
obvious but there have been a couple of
points in history where a union between
the two has been proposed the same is
also true for the rest of britain's
former colonies in the caribbean where
the same idea was put forward in the
1960s so why didn't it happen why isn't
jamaica or any of these countries a part
of canada so in the 19th century there
were some small scale discussions on who
should be able to join the brand new
canadian confederation britain was
fairly neutral on whether or not its
caribbean territories would be run from
london or ottawa this was because a
colony of a colony is still really a
colony and also britain's attention was
much more focused on india because money
this discussion was mostly academic
though until after the first world war
at this point britain was struggling
with being broke as such british prime
minister david lloyd george wanted to
consolidate the governments of some
colonies to make things cheaper and one
such proposal was that canada which was
much less bankrupt would run the
empire's caribbean colonies but canada's
prime minister robert borden declined
not because he didn't want the islands
he definitely did mostly his
compensation for all of the world
warring that canada had been doing he
reluctantly declined though because the
canadian people opposed it many of whom
including the opposition saw empire as
the reason why canada had been dragged
into the conflict in the first place and
as such jamaica remained under the
control of london during world war ii
britain's relationship with its
caribbean colonies became strained and
as a result canada filled the void and
relations between the two improved the
british government could see that its
empire was unravelling and so it opted
to begin the process of preparing the
caribbean for independence it did this
with the least effort possible in what's
known as boilerplate independence this
is where britain used a
one-size-fits-all approach to
decolonization britain didn't want to
repeat this process 10 times and so it
just merged all of its caribbean
colonies together to form the west
indies federation during this process it
was discussed whether or not they would
become independent or simply join canada
as a single province some of the islands
were pro-canada and others notably
jamaica were pro-independents the
leaders of the federation couldn't agree
on basically anything and so it
fractured in 1962 and one by one each
part became independent and so after
their freedom surely there was no desire
for any of these countries to join
canada right well there were two the
first was british honduras whose
interest was much more about britain
doing a terrible job of preparing it for
independence than any real desire to
join another nation honduras and its
neighbor guatemala had many
disagreements on borders access to the
sea and trade and britain didn't care
enough to fix any of these problems
which is why some politicians in
honduras pushed to join canada this
never went anywhere and british honduras
gained full independence as belize in
1981. the second was the turks and
caicos islands here the people who lived
there wanted much better access to other
markets and countries for themselves and
for their goods but britain was in a no
foreigners please kind of mood and so
politicians there discussed the idea of
joining canada this proposal gained
steam until the 1980s when some
prominent canadian politicians backed
the idea and official talks between the
two took place most of the islanders
back joining canada but the canadian
people were very focused on another
divisive issue at home a free trade
agreement with the united states this
debate raged for years and was so
important to canadians that nobody had
any desire to discuss grabbing a few
caribbean islands and what that would
entail and given that this debate took
about a decade to settle down the idea
of annexing a caribbean island just sort
of faded leaving canada without a hawaii
of its own i hope you enjoyed this
episode and a special thanks to my
patrons james bisonette kelly money
maker skye chappelle corsa wolff jerry
landon jordan longley adam stalter
marcus arsenault wyan hockey spencer
lightfoot rod d martin words about books
podcast captain cydog gustav swan marvin
cassell common yoon winston k wood
boogie wiggly daniel to be in miss
izzette matthew shipley aaron the white
corey turner the mcwhopper alex schwinn
anthony beckett coppertone maggie
patzkowski she went in spinning three
plates and charles the first